i got to ask you about love
i heard you're into this now into this
love thing yeah is this
do you think this is your solution to
your depression no
i'm just trying to like you said the
enlightened people on occasion trying to
sell a book i'm writing a book about
love you're writing a book about me no
i'm not
a friend of mine somebody said you
should really write a book about
your you know your management philosophy
you said it'd be a short book
well that one was all pretty well uh
what role do you think love
family friendship all that kind of uh
human stuff play in a successful life
you've been exceptionally successful in
the space of
like running teams building cool in
this world
creating some amazing things what uh did
love get in the way did love help
the family get in the way to family help
friendship you want the engineer's
answer
please so but first love is functional
right
it's functional in what way so we
habituate ourselves to the environment
and actually jordan told me jordan
peterson told me this line
so you go through life and you just get
used to everything except for the things
you love
they they remain new like this is really
useful for
you know like like other people's
children and dogs and you know trees
you just don't pay that much attention
to your own kids you monitor them really
closely
like and if they go off a little bit
because you love them if you're smart
if you're going to be a successful
parent you notice it right away
you don't habituate to
just things you love and if you want to
be successful at work if you don't love
it
you're not going to put the time in
somebody else as somebody else that
loves it
like because it's new and interesting
and that lets you go to the next level
so it's the thing it's just a function
that generates newness
and novelty and uh surprises you know
those kind of
it's really interesting and there's
people figured out lots of you know
frameworks for this
you know like like humans seem to go in
partnership go through
you know interest like somebody suddenly
somebody's interesting
and then you're infatuated with them and
then you're in love with them
and then you you know different people
have ideas about parental love or mature
love like you go through a cycle of that
which keeps us together and it's you
know super functional for creating
families and
and creating communities and making you
support somebody despite the fact that
you don't love them
like and and
it can be really enriching you know
now in the work life balance scheme if
all
you do is work you think you may be
optimizing your work potential but if
you don't love your work or you don't
have
family and friends and things you care
about
your brain isn't well balanced like
everybody knows the experience of you
works on something all week you went
home and took two days
off and you came back in the odds of you
working on the thing you
picking up rate where you left off is
zero your brain refactored it
but being in blood was great it's like
changes the color of the light in the
room
it creates a spaciousness that's that's
different it helps you think
it makes you strong bokowski had this
line about
love being a fog that dissipates with
the first light of reality
in the morning it's that's depressing i
think it's the other way around
it lasts well you like you said it's a
function it's a thing that just
be the light that actually enlivens your
world and creates the interest and the
power and the strength and the
to go do something well it's like
like that sounds like you know there's
like physical love emotional
of intellectual love spirituality yeah
right isn't it all the same thing kind
of
nope you should differentiate that maybe
that's your problem
in your book you should you should
refine that a little bit different
chapters
yeah there's different chapters what's
that what's these are the aren't these
just different layers of the same thing
or the stack
physical people people some people are
addicted to physical love and they have
no idea about emotional or intellectual
love
i don't know if they're the same things
i think they're different that's true
they could be different
and it'd be it i guess the ultimate goal
is for it to be the same well if you
want something to be bigger and
interesting you should find all its
components and differentiate them not
climb it together
people do this all the time they yeah
the modularity
get your abstraction layers right and
then you can you have room to breathe
well maybe you can write the forward to
my book about love
yeah or the afterwards and the after you
really tried
i feel like lex has made a lot of
progress in this book but
uh well you have things in your life
that you love yeah
yeah you know so and they are you're
right they're modular
it's it's and you can have multiple
things with the same person or the same
thing and yeah but
yeah depending on the moment of the day
yeah there's
like what bukowski described as that
moment and you go from being
in love to having a different kind of
love yeah
right and that's a transition but when
it happens if you read the owner's
manual and
you believed it you would have said oh
this happened
it doesn't mean it's not love it's a
different kind of love
but but maybe there's something better
about that as you grow old if
all you do is regret how you used to be
it's sad right you should have learned a
lot of things because
like who you can be in your future self
is is actually more interesting and
possibly delightful than you know being
a mad kid
in love with the the next person like
that's super fun when it happens but
that's
that's you know five percent of the
possibility
but yeah that's right that there's a lot
more fun to be had in the long lasting
stuff
yeah or meaning you know if that's me
which is a kind of fun
it's a deeper kind of fun and it's
surprising you know that's
like like the thing i like is surprises
you know and you just never know what's
going to happen
yeah but you have to look carefully and
you have to work at it you have to think
about it
you know it's yeah you have to see the
surprises when they happen right you
have to be
looking for it
you